(marching band music)
(loud chomp)
(screams)
♪ Brickleberry ♪
- (sniffs) Mmm, 2009 Baja Red.
Playful on the nose,
very dry on the palette,
hints of eucalyptus, stone
fruits and kalamala olives.
- Do you know what that is?
- Is that the Devil's penis?
- No.
(laughs maniacally)
- Man, (bleeps) nature.
- I can't take being white,
I gotta get back to my roots.
- Ow, hey, ow, stop it, oh!
God damn!
Um, hey warden, that's
a really nice tie.
Take that Malloy!
Ow!
Wait wait wait I
thought my friend
had to suffer for my sins?
- I was being sarcastic, idiot!
- (screams) Anti-Christ,
Anti-christ!
- This is going too far, Denzel.
- That baby's evil,
I'll prove it.
- How?
- Through science.
If I shoot it in the face
and it lives, it's the Devil.
- Okay, okay, shoot it
if it will shut you up.
- Whoa!
Whoa!
Oh shit!
(cats meowing and howling)
Man, y'all are freaks.
I bet you ain't smiled like that
since you got the right to vote.
So last night when my
girl says she wanted
to slip into something
more comfortable,
I didn't know she meant a coma.
(laughs)
Hey, what's wrong with
you, that's funny.
I mean it's sad too,
'cause she died.
♪ Brickleberry ♪